alors en 79 Berger Blanc qui ont proposé
Starmania t'a refusé tu as dit qu'est-ce
que c'est cette comédie musicale
française
t'es bien informé
du bois bonsoir le Québec est une star
énorme
[Musique]
des stades avec 30000 personnes il
paraissent
ces espèces de fêtes
estivales d'été quoi ou aujourd'hui on
raconte on rencontre 50 60 000 personnes
sur un show ou alors en fait il est
arrivé où on a fait des spectacles en
plein centre de la ville de Québec
puisqu'on parle du Québec et où on a
rencontré je sais pas 45000 personnes
mais il y a l'espèce de magie on arrive
avec les motos comme ça j'ai mélangé si
tu veux un peu les mémés avec les
motards les enfants avec les freaks tout
le monde tout à l'heure la bande
pardonne tout il paraît
où on me pardonne alors en 79 bergers et
blamandantes ont proposé Starmania t'a
refusé tu as dit qu'est-ce que c'est
cette comédie musicale français
tu es bien informé je sais que je sais
tout ouais mais ça correspondait pas
tellement à l'époque tu sais j'étais
j'habitais Berville Woodstock dans
l'État de New York et j'avoue que je
m'éclatais un peu mieux tu vois à faire
un espèce de musique complètement craqué
plutôt ouais faire des comédies
musicales j'ai pas tellement été un
enfant de de l'école du spectacle moi
j'ai plutôt été un avorté de la rue
non pas vraiment par contre tu es venu à
Paris enregistrer le businessman j'avais
reçu donc un téléphone qui m'offrait de
faire cette chanson et j'avais demandé
vous voulez me l'envoyer quand même
histoire que je l'écoute ils m'ont dit
non non mais viens à Paris ça tombait
bien j'avais besoin de deux semaines de
vacances je suis venu écouter ça m'a plu
c'est une chanson qui m'a beaucoup plu
donc j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à
l'enregistrer bon et maintenant c'est
donner un tube énorme en plus par toi au
Canada non
c'est un hymne national
c'est quand même un classique si on veut
c'est quelque chose qui est très établi
et que tout le monde connaît à tel point
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont jamais fait la
relation entre Starmania et cette
chanson
alors en 82 tu as eu des problèmes
[Musique]
de drogue ça a donné un peu plus cher
que tu avais fait
mais je me suis trouvé à la mauvaise
placement non et donc ce que j'ai fait
je me suis fait prendre une chose qu'on
peut pas faire dans la drogue c'est se
faire prendre mais tu t'es fait prendre
je vais consommer
on a un peu fait un espèce d'exemple
public
[Musique]
sauvetage malgré moi en fin de compte
que ce truc me soit arrivé ça va un peu
sauver la vie ça fait un peu genre
pas vraiment
ça dépend de ce dont on parle il y a des
choses qui pour moi ne sont pas de la
drogue mais ce qu'on appelle
[Musique]
beaucoup beaucoup
et finalement je pense que ranger cette
quantité là c'est plus très drôle
vraiment l'enfer alors évidemment ça a
été comme un espèce de renouveau
merveilleux le peu de tôle que j'ai fait
si on considère que deux ans c'est pas
beaucoup
quand même certains temps avant de
revenir de tout ça et ça a provoqué des
ratés dans ta carrière c'est à dire
en retard par exemple c'est à cause de
ça maintenant je crois que je pense que
je pense que j'en avais rien à faire
c'était pas très préoccupé si on veut
par la carrière j'ai jamais été j'ai
jamais été un enragé du métier
maintenant d'ailleurs on m'engueule
encore beaucoup le choix même si je suis
plus un drogué j'étais encore j'ai quand
même gardé ce côté
pour moi la liberté la chose la plus
importante au monde
là j'ai écrit c'est fabuleux il s'agit
finalement de se dire j'ai fermé la
porte à clé et non pas on m'a enfermé
fallait pas être trop nombreux dans la
cellule quand même on est pas beaucoup
avant on est tout seul dans les Canada
vous êtes tout seul sur deux ans oui si
on passe qu'un jour alors là on fait son
groupe c'est les groupes thérapeutiques
oui alors justement en parlant de groupe
thérapeutique
c'est quoi c'est une thérapie de groupe
c'est un peu basé si on veut sur très
ancien comme méthode j'ai peut-être il y
a eu un endroit qui s'appelle d'étapes à
New York qui est en plein centre où on
appelle niddle Park c'est à dire que par
la vitre par la fenêtre tu vois et tu
vois des gens qui dans le parc pendant
que toi tu es en train de te
désintoxiquer alors c'est assez génial
comme comme école d'amis combien de
temps pour désintoxiquer là-bas oh j'ai
mis je crois qu'après quatre mois
c'était quand même assez net mais
j'avais quand même fait deux ans de
tolérance j'avais donc pris une espèce
de décision d'arrêter roto parce qu'en
tant que c'était très facile à mettre
plus qu'à l'extérieur ah bon ah oui
à l'extérieur
et l'approbation c'était quoi après elle
approbation elle est encore là
d'ailleurs
la France
ça s'est passé comment alors le
journaliste c'est vrai effectivement
[Musique]
j'ai pas vécu ça si tu veux avec
amertume finalement au bout de tout ça
j'ai rencontré d'abord des gens qui ont
vécu des choses beaucoup plus dures que
moi et ça a été quelque chose de
fabuleux une fois que c'est terminé
évidemment parce que pendant lui c'est
un peu dur une fois que c'est passé tout
ça je crois que c'est très enrichissant
à personne
[Musique]
c'est vraiment quelque chose de plus il
me semble que c'est plus blues rock
c'est beaucoup plus mon concept aussi
c'est un peu dans ce signe que je me
faisais déjà dans les spectacles et tout
il faut dire que dans le contexte de la
comédie musicale c'est quelque chose
d'assez statique très dur comme ça qui
va avec les personnes mais je pense que
le disque va donner beaucoup plus côté
émotion et c'est plus
évidente
de
Richard qui était le l'hôpital
j'ai du monde qui sont très ouverts
la danse dans une espèce de tour assez
spécial le Concorde Lafayette mais je me
sauve quand même je glisse et comment tu
fais pour trouver de l'ado à Paris alors
j'ai regardé les autres facile
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu